hello everybody i'm jesse waters along
with juan williams
martha mccallum greg gutfeld and judge
janine
it's five o'clock in new york city and
this is the five
it's a huge weekend for conservatives at
cpac down in florida
a lineup of heavy-hitting republicans
have been taking on joe biden and his
radical agenda while also calling out
cancel culture and the left's love of
socialism
conservatives explaining how they plan
to counter biden and the democrats take
a look
we are an oasis of freedom in a nation
that's suffering
in many parts of the country under the
yoke of oppressive lockdowns
florida got it right and the lockdown
states got it wrong
the left of of course does hate the bill
of rights why
well because the bill of rights talks
about things that the government
can't do and that to them is like
blasphemy joe biden and the radicals in
his administration they are already
overshooting they are
already going too far their policies
don't work
they are disasters there is no more
pernicious threat to america
than the rejection of our founding
principles and our heritage
and our tradition they don't want to
compete with us in the battle of ideas
because they know they lose they just
want to cancel us i want to make sure
you're all aware of president biden's
new slogan
open borders and closed schools
and donald trump is set to return to the
national spotlight with a big speech at
cpac on sunday
the former president is expected to rip
apart joe biden's disastrous policies
and lay out a path for republicans to
retake congress
in 2022. judge jeanine is
down there at cpac in orlando
all right two questions for you judge
jeanine who had the biggest response
so far of all the speakers that you saw
and what was the general theme
of most of the speeches in your opinion
well i think that you know it really was
a tie
between ron desantis and ted cruz uh in
terms of the greatest applause
uh ted cruz was very fiery i mean he was
he was taking no prisoners today and in
terms of the theme
jesse it was all about you know getting
back to
america and the america that our
founding fathers intended
and that means freedom of speech the
second amendment
the ability to survive in a country
where leftist
leftists and socialism seems to be the
desire
and it was almost like i felt that it
was a run-up to a presidential primary
that all the big contenders were there
that they were getting ready for the big
game
that they wanted to be seen as a person
who for example
mike league talked about the bill of
rights each
each candidate so to speak up there from
ron desantis talking about covet and how
his state was open
and it was a theme that played
throughout the whole day
because when you get to america jesse
especially if you're from
new york if you get to florida you
realize everything's open the sun is
shining the restaurants are open people
are happy and uh i did a little
old-fashioned street justice jesse and
you'll see it tomorrow night on my show
so that was fun too good good and aren't
you speaking down there as well
i i was on with tommy laron and
lawrence jones but i'm not speaking here
but i'll be doing my showdown here
and we're going to have a preview of uh
what's going on here when i do my show
tomorrow night
excellent all right greg gutfeld you've
covered cpac for many years we
i think you remember when breitbart was
down there
and it was kind of a merry band a
prankster's kind of scene it's evolved
a lot differently over the years what's
your interpretation of cpac in 2021
i'm just thinking when i i read eye the
old show
we actually did we opened for ann
coulter like an opening band
and we're up on stage i can't remember
it must have been 2008 or 2009.
um i think it has to do a little bit of
an evolution and maybe it naturally it
will happen sometimes it always feels
that it's hard to tell one year from the
next with cpac
because the themes are often very very
very
similar and i'm sure you could say that
about uh liberal events as well
but lover hey trump you know he opened
america's eyes to the power of media
narratives and i think
um he he the right has to understand
that they're coming for you and and i
think it's important that we that we
uh whether you're rightists or
libertarians stemming the media
tied of domestic terror propaganda if
you aren't voting democrat you're a
danger to the republic
i think it's going to be the next three
years message
um and everything they said about you as
a person from 2016 to 2020
will be nothing compared to what they
say about you in this full full-court
demonization
press so i think it's really important
that
that the new breed and the new blood is
up for that
challenge and also reaching out to the
new type of voters that are coming to
the republican party i'm talking about
the ones that are leaving the democratic
party
the blue-collar workers the people who
are seeing their rights
their free speech being hindered they're
you know how can you be part of a party
that won't
stand up for you when there's threat of
cancellation so i think you know
looking at like let's look at tucker's
show tucker's show is extremely
successful
but it's not cookie cutter conservatism
he's
looking at the diminished middle class
and the complete shafting of the working
class
that should be what the republican party
should look at
that makes sense it does seem to me
martha that those themes have been
emerging at cpac
if you've listened to desantis talk
about immigration or matt gates
talk about industrial policy those
themes are there
and i think that's probably due to
donald trump's
philosophical influence
yeah no doubt and one of the things that
i like to do
you know is go back and look at some of
these old speeches
and today i went back and looked at uh
president trump former president trump's
2011 speech
at cpac which is really you know there
was all this energy in the room and
everybody was all excited they said he
was the surprise guest and he came out
and sort of
you know tempted everybody with maybe
i'm gonna run in uh 2012 and then
uh of course he ran in 2016 and just two
months after that speech
at cpac barack obama then president came
out at the white house correspondents
dinner and tried to
roast donald trump in the audience right
which made me
realize you know what a threat he
recognized at that point
um it was pretty clear that donald trump
was emerging on the scene in a very big
way
so watching all of these guys today i
just couldn't help but think you know
they're all
trying to have that magic you know this
is why i love to cover politics they're
all trying to see if they can get that
crowd
going but can they do it to the extent
that he was able to then
and that i think he's still able to when
he gets out there on sunday night
there's just there's just no no
comparison in terms of who can get that
crowd
riled up at cpac no doubt
so sunday juan you'll be glued to the tv
watching donald trump re-emerge
after um after going down to mar-a-lago
for a little hiatus
what are you expecting from donald trump
are you happy that he's back on the
scene
are you concerned what does juan
williams think
uh jesse i think only one thing can come
out of cpac that really matters
and it's donald trump's speech and it's
whether or not donald trump
uh says oh you know what that election
was stolen and i still want my
fair treatment and i think we need to
fix the system because it was stolen or
does he say you know what i was wrong
and joe biden is a legitimate president
of this country and we need to move on
uh you know to me all he if he's talks
about
cancel culture if he starts talking
about the size of the stimulus package
it doesn't affect anything that impacts
me or you uh it's all about whether or
not he stands with the people who
conducted that january 6th insurrection
or ready whether he says
those people behaved abysmally and they
don't deserve our
support i mean i think you know speaking
to what you've been mentioning
i think he's going to leave open 2024
because
that's a leverage point for him in terms
of exercising
some power over all the people that
judge jeanine mentioned who
are up there trying to you know be the
heir apparent to donald trump and the
republican party
but i just don't think that there's
makes much difference
about 2024 even though mitch mcconnell
now says he would back donald trump if
he is the nominee in 24 i just don't
think that's it i think what it is
is does donald trump finally say i got
beat
in 2020.
i don't expect to hear that but i do
expect him to look forward
[Laughter]
coming up here